You have an amazing smile.
I like how you smile with your whole face.
It makes me happy.
A viral New York Times article featured
36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people falling in love.
We want it to see what would happen if
we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name is Sonia. I'm from a city called
Sarnia outside of Toronto in Canada.
And I'm single.
I feel like my whole job is being in
front of cameras and I'm never nervous.
I'm a little nervous. I got a
little, I'm a little clammy.
I've never been on a blind date. So
this is, this is out of my element.
My name is James.
I am from Thailand and I'm single.
Have you ever been on a blind
date? I don't think so. No.
Yeah. No, I get that. Yeah,
it's like warm, but
it's not warm. It's not.
Hi. Hi. Hi. It's Tanya James. Gotcha.
Alright, so we're gonna have some
tea I guess. So. Cheers. Cheers.
That's going to I, you want to smell
myself? Yeah, it's really hot too.
We don't have napkins. You have questions,
so probably start so that this is not,
you want to go first? Sure.
Okay. Complete this sentence.
I wish I had someone with whom
I could share and ventures.
Hmm. I think it was the first
thing that came to my mind.
I think work is extremely important,
but I'm also,
I feel very spontaneous where I'm like,
you know what? Today I'm going here.
I'm going to just like go to San
Diego for the day, or what the hell?
I got a copy of it. Yeah.
Being able to share it.
Ventures would be required
of someone. Yeah. Instead of
having to be like, no, no,
we need to plan and do all that,
which I genuinely am and can be.
It's good to have both. Yeah. Yeah. If
you're going like some were international,
it's like, okay, let's
like look at some places.
I think I'm also like very blessed
to have a schedule that allows me,
because I feel like a lot of people
don't getting it soon. There you go.
I'm believing. Yeah. Believing it more
regular job to become more flexible,
so that's nice. That'll be good. Yeah.
When did you last sing to
yourself or to someone else?
I always sing to warm up my voice.
I have an audition or something.
Do you have a good singing voice or um,
my saint choir in high school.
So what would you say?
Um, no pressure. There's no
cameras. There was nobody.
No, of course not. For example,
a good song. Uh, do you know,
go steal cars for Rose Rose?
It's a little high for me.
I think I see a shiny,
Eh,
used to be a green towel.
No, no, no. I'm see he,
you remain alone.
The dots me
this, Huh? For something.
So then it was beautiful.
Thank you. So I had kind of a throwback
day and the other day I was like,
I need something to go on
when I'm cleaning. And then
I got caught on incubus.
Okay. I got stuck on like
the morning view albums.
I was like blaring some incubus cleaning
my room like a couple of days ago.
So that was probably last time I sang.
Aw. What is your most treasured memory?
I have too many man. Aw,
that's a good feeling though
because of how unique my school was
and the people I was waiting, you know,
international school,
everyone's from everywhere.
There was some weird thing too about my
grade where we kind of just overstepped
any of these like I guess
social boundaries and like
everyone just got super
close. Are you still friends
with a lot of them? Yeah.
Actually the reason I play pub g so much
is because most of my friends are my
old school friends and they're
now they're in Thailand. Yeah.
So you know there's Latin see which sucks.
But like they're the ones that got me
on it and I was like I don't want to do
this as then suddenly we'd been
playing for like four months straight.
Isn't it crazy how gaming
can be such a bridge? Yeah.
And just like keep your conduct.
Yeah.
Cause people I haven't talked to in
years that just hopped on this train and
suddenly we were like gaming
on the weekends together.
There was somebody that I,
I played league of legends with for
like four years and I never met them.
And then randomly at an event in La,
this person comes up to me and he's like
Sanja Coz we knew what each other look
like from social media and we just so
happen to run into each other after five
years of playing league of legends
together just randomly on the street.
It's crazy. I, it just like
connects people like that.
I feel like I kind of feel the same
way. I feel like I have a lot. One more,
I feel like I was like particularly
proud of myself was last summer I was
hosting like a,
like a conference for a three.
There was a whole bunch of things kind
of leading up to it where I was told I
was going to have a prompt her and
I didn't. So I had nothing prepared,
didn't have a teleprompter.
And it was like a minute before we were
alive and it was like tens of millions
of people. Like they're like, all
right, 30 seconds. And I blanked. Oh.
And I had no idea. I didn't even
know what event I was at anymore.
I'm like, I gotta just say
words. And they're like, all
right, 10 seconds. I'm like,
I don't even know my name. I
trust, I just spewed stuff out.
And for the rest of the two hour show
I just like nailed it. I nailed it. Oh,
it was so proud of myself
because I'm like, I had nothing.
I had nothing prepared and I
didn't know how to do anything.
And after I did that, I was like, I'm
like, I feel like I can do anything now.
It's like the years of practice, like led
up to that in the worst circumstances.
It's like, all right. And
then it just worked out.
So, hey, that's awesome. That was rough.
What your most terrible memory?
Oh Man.
On the flip coin of what I just said,
I think I also have a lot
of terrible memory. Yes.
At one point I was living back with my
mom and things weren't really working out,
but she wasn't very communicative of
like why it wasn't working out in why she
was frustrated and why things were bad.
And she told,
um, the children's aid society too,
that she didn't want me anymore.
And instead of like surrendering me,
she left the house,
she didn't tell me where she was going
and then she had the children's aid
society and the police and just show
up and just randomly take me back into
foster care after,
you know,
I had been there for a couple
of years and then I finally,
it was free and I was with my mom. It was
just randomly, I was just any other day.
It was like a Saturday.
I was just at home.
I was like on MSN or like something and
I just heard a knock at the door and
then my whole life was just
like shit flipped upside down,
like in a blink of an eye and it
was just back in foster care again.
It just like re dug up all of those like
shitty emotions and everything that I
sort of pushed this side cause I'm like,
oh, I'm free now. But then it's like, no,
I'm not. Yeah, it's not. How Fun.
What about you?
Um,
it was um,
a drunken Halloween night and someone
I had been kind of involved with,
she had gotten punched my bouncer.
Oh yeah, she got really angry too, cause
she knew the owner and she was like, no,
I want to go back in and talk to him. Ask
Him why this happened. Long story short,
we ended up going back in and I was
trying to stop her without like physically
stopping her and she
wasn't having any of that
and it basically ended up like
us getting jumped by like,
I don't know what the total
number of bouncers was,
but it was definitely like five to seven
ish. In that moment I was just like,
oh my God, am I going to die?
Is she going to die? Or we just,
what is it going to happen? I don't
know. So it was just a really,
really bad situation
I think. Any, any event that you like
a question, if you're going to look,
yeah, it's usually not one
that's, yeah, I'm sorry. Yeah,
I can't speak for her, but there's
no permanent emotional damage for me.
So I'm to,
and I've learned from that situation.
So when did you last cry?
In front of another person or by herself?
There's two questions I guess.
I'm a very emotional person.
I feel like two days ago I've been having
like a really emotional week and I'm
not very close with my dad anymore.
He's still in Canada and he'll
text me like once a month,
once like maybe twice a month.
And I've been feeling really down about
stuff that I've been doing and stuff
that I've been working on projects.
And he said like he said something along
the lines of when you were younger I
always saw you as an artist and I'm
proud of where you are or something like
that. And I was like, cause it was just
perfect. It was like perfect timing.
I was feeling shitty and it was just
like exactly what I needed to hear and it
like really hit me.
What about you?
Last time I cry by myself was yesterday
cause I saw some video on reddit about
two little girls who were like facetime
besties and their parents were besties
and then they only met by facetime because
they live far away from each other.
But it was like the first
time they met in. Yeah,
I think like, yeah, it was so cute.
Okay, well now that I think about it,
there was a really cute pit bull video.
I saw it yesterday.
It was like a pit bull. How goofy I isn't
this family just like loved it so much.
I hate it when cute stuff makes me cry.
It's like I'm so holy,
it's so wholesome but then like I'm
crawling over and it's like good.
It's happy to alternate sharing something
you consider a positive characteristic
of your partner. Share a total
of three items. Oh, okay.
Alternate between the, okay.
There's like alternate between positive
and negative. Yeah. Tell me some negative.
Yeah. Geez. Okay. Um,
right because it's me for,
do you have a great sense of humor?
Thanks. I like your sense of humor. Yeah.
You have an amazing smile.
I like how you smile with your
whole face and it makes me happy.
Smile with like your like your eyes,
your everything.
Everything is engaged in your
smile. Thank you. I like it.
I like that you're humble but you
also know what your strengths are.
Thanks.
I wanted to say something about your hair.
We're too,
cause I really were reversed. We
have a similar sense of humor. Yeah.
Besides the humor thing, like I just
get a feeling that you've, you know,
even through like acting
classes and stuff like that,
you've done a lot of like self
discovery and I feel like you're,
you're pretty aware of who you are,
which is cool.
Your hair looks like it belongs
in a shampoo commercial.
Really? Yeah. I'll tell you it's actually
pretty dry but I'll take it. I liked the,
I liked that you can be vulnerable. I feel
like a lot of people aren't, you know,
super open and they kind of, you know,
push things aside or they like don't,
aren't as communicative about things.
But I feel like you seem
like you can be vulnerable.
I mean you're here having tea with me in
front of cameras so I appreciate that.
Thank you. This is the last one. Would
you go on a second day with your partner?
Aw
Yeah.
That took a while though.
I was gauging your reaction cause I was
like listen to you can, you can say no.
Oh I'm told it will be offensive to
answer first. Oh okay. Yeah. I don't know.
Yeah, I think it would. Yeah, no,
definitely. Would you as well? Uh,
I might have to,
I don't know about that one.
Everything was so great but then
she did fingers and I'm out.
Want me to top you up? Yeah,
final for final cheers.
Okay,
well cheers to that being catfished.
Yes,
just take it like a shot.
I don't know why Jay was like a habit.
I was just like how it that is telling
me and then you'll see it's okay.
That's great.
Hey guys, this is Jason
and I have total, yeah,
we want to say thank you so much for
watching another episode of tea for two.
We love the series and we hope you guys
do as well. We have a question for you.
What is your most treasured memory? Tell
us in the comments below. I'll try it.
And as always,
make sure you subscribe and click here
to watch more videos and we will see you
next time.